Welcome everybody to a do a zoom call looks like everybody here is
A veteran so we're gonna jump into the questions right away. I just come to understand that even organic meat
could come from animals
That have been vaccinated especially since they cannot use antibiotics
Do you have any thoughts or recommendations and how we can all mitigate the damage coming our way from the recently publicized M
RDA vaccines that are being used or
Are going to be used in our animal products or even regular vaccine products
But that we are already eating our organic meat
This is really a tough one because this is heartbreaking
Now actually you could read that they're actually
using M RDA
technology and
vaccinating
clients so some of the foods that you're buying even in all foods market are
vaccinating if you look at Mercola site
He's done some articles on this some other people have done some articles on this and they're probably that they think that they're doing the world a favor by putting
M RDA
Vaccines in in our plants in our animals
It's it's very disheartening. How do you get away from this?
And the only way that I think that you can get away from this all together is to be tried your best to grow your own food
buy from
You know local co-ops that you know that and you trust the people that are growing your food. There are
meat
livestock
animal ranchers that
Are you know put it out there that they are not ever vaccinating their animals
I saw an Instagram video of a company that
A cattle ranch that said we will never vaccinate our animals
We don't you know when going on and on about how everything that they try to do is
the organic is possible and
And they are very up front with their statements. I did go to their website
And unfortunately you pay a whole lot more for the meat, you know, I think it was
It was I can't remember now because it was a few weeks ago that my wife said hey look up this cattle ranch and
Because she shared a Instagram post with me and I looked it up and it was like
Well in dollars a pound for hamburger
Maybe it was even more than that
So it was like oh
This is expensive, you know when you're trying to
feed your you know when you have you know, 15 of your grandkids coming over and
You know and another 10 adults it's gets to be expensive feeding everybody so
You're raising a family. It can be extremely expensive to try to do things
correct
The you know, we you know, we needed my wife
And I we are huge gardeners. I've already alluded to that
Someday I'll share pictures of our garden. Maybe next week. I'll remember it takes a picture some chairs and pictures of our garden
Um, they were very proud of
But it's so much work. We just both love to do it
Um, and we do of course everything is organic. We don't use anything not organic on it
Um, and we do yeah, we do it because we eat all our own food. We share it with our children and grandchildren
But we do it mainly to be honest because we love to do it
I don't know when I was a little kid. I wanted to be a farmer. So um
You know
We put it in the sweet corn last year
That was a hundred percent organic sweet corn from Saudi seeds
Share it with our family our grandkids literally just ate it right off the stock
It without cooking it it was so good
Um
That we put in a whole bunch more of this year
But you still I mean we we did it can and we froze a bunch of it
But literally my wife and I finished everything that we froze within a month. We tried to save two bags for Thanksgiving
um, but you
To produce enough food for a family
If you're doing it yourself is very very difficult, you know throughout this whole COVID thing
Ever you know you hear all this talk about people out
Oh, we're just going to go behind a hundred acres and live off the land. Okay, most people have no idea how much work that is
So maybe my you guys do but most people have no idea how much work that is years ago
My wife and I and then we had
Three kids at the time
We lived off the land. We lived up on 270 acres of the middle of the woods on a river
Completely off grid for three and a half years and my sister and brother-in-law of the sister who works for me marine
lived there too then for two and a half years of that time
And it is I tell you we were a lot younger than so it is very difficult
Down my wife and I do a lot of guardian my wife mainly does the flowers. I do mainly the vegetables
And it is exhausting to try to live off of everything that you make and grow and eat is
You know for most people it's just not doable
So how do you navigate this?
I don't know you can't even trust the organic stuff that you buy anymore
Bottom line is you just have to do your best you just do the best that you possibly can
And you have to trust God for the difference because otherwise you'll go crazy
So and I don't think that it is
It is reasonable
to
To put that on yourself or on anybody that you have to grow all your own food
um, I just think this is the fate of what's going on in the world now and we're getting close to the end and
I just
Can't see how
How he would population is going to navigate these mRNA vaccines that are coming our way so
Just do your best try to do your best. That's all I could say
My naturopathic doctor recently commented that the only scan
Available that truly identifies a truer tuber as biologically active
Beauty living cancer cells is a pet scan
All other scans including the pre-dubo just detect a mass
We assume obviously if the mat if the size is growing that's an active cancer, but
If we've got a lump that's really staying the same size there's no way to know if it's by a broader tissue
Or cancer or something else do I agree?
um
The answer that is yes, I do agree
And
I'll go even one step further just because it's showing up as metabolically active on a pet scan doesn't mean it's necessarily growing
So I mean any living tissue is going to have metabolic activity what a pet scan's looking for is that difference in metabolic activity
Is it highly metabolic that's going to as they tune their instrument
um, you know, they're looking for where there's higher metabolic activity in an area
So yes, I would totally agree that a pet scan is the only way to show and to scan what is metabolically active
Everything else is going to look at a bass. They can't look at whether it's living tissue growing tissue or anything else
But a pet scan still can't even say that it's growing
So um out of if you really want to know if there's up cancer in other places
A pet scan is really the best scan
Now the the reason why a person would choose the pernoval over a pet scan is simply because of the radiation
Issue with a pet scan you're getting radiation and you're having to take a sugar dose with pet a pet scan
And some people are opposed to doing that and understandable
So you just have to weigh it out what you're really looking for if you know you have cancer
And you know what's active and you just want to know if you have cancer somewhere else
you need a pre-novo
Is the least invasive of those but if you
If you haven't had a lot of pet scans you haven't had a lot of CT scans
Um, then you know getting a pet scan done
Is is
More accurate I would say so but it comes with it the
Invasiveness of the radiation and the invasiveness of having to take the glucose syrup
So that's where people go against it
But again, remember all those things it's it's it's the radiation is
What's is measured and what's called a rad dose
The more radiation that you get throughout your lifetime the more damaging it's gonna be so if you're like
All I've got is dental x-rays and maybe some x-rays at my car practice
Um, and I got an MRI to diagnose my cancer. I haven't even had a pet scan or CT scan
Um, but now you know, I have I have some bone pain or you have you have suspect of metastasis
Um, then you know go ahead and do a pet scan if you're simply
using the pet scan
Um, and doing a test just on a curiosity to see if there's metabolic activity
And things are growing that I would question that remember my my whole
The saying about doing a invasive test as you do an invasive test is if it's gonna change the way you treat
the patient so
And you as a patient you would choose to do an invasive test if you're gonna choose to change the way you treat it
If you're gonna go if you're saying I'm just curious if the cancer in my breast is is
Metabolically active and growing um, I'm not gonna do anything different. I'm gonna keep doing what I'm doing
Well, then then I wouldn't do it
But if it's like okay, I have this horrible pain in my spine and I want to make sure that I don't have you know
metastasis to the spine and if I did I would
I might opt to do radiation or something because this is really bothering me
Well, then that's a reason to do a pet scan because it may change the way you treat it
I just started using the rife last night and I have two more weeks of radiology
to undergo
Because of the two targeted lesions
That are so dangerous so close to pressing a white spinal cord
Is it okay to continue with the radiation while using the rife? Yes
My opinion is yes, my opinion is yes, it will actually help target the radiation
To the cancer because you're hitting the cancer with its own frequencies while you have radiation in your body
So I think it would even work better. So yes
Have you heard of the sygnetera test
personalized blood test that detects your
cancer circulated tuber
D&A
used to detect relapse
measure
treatment
for
efficacy
And it's covered by insurance for a medium to late-stage cancer solid tuber cancers
So if you could do a test like this that is going to
measure
circulated tumor D&A
D&A that is covered by insurance and by all means go ahead and do it there's it is a blood test
And it's not going to be invasive
But if you have to pay out a pocket you're spending $2,000 for it
It's not giving you quantitative data that is going to be able to measure
You know, it's just
That whether it's going to go up or down
So there's positives and negatives to this test
But
That was the beauty of the IVG test when we had that it gave you more quantitative numbers so that you could see if your cancer is getting worse or better
This will tell you if your cancer is active but it doesn't tell you how active it doesn't you know give you that that same
same data
But it could be helpful
It's
It's not a perfect test but you have to remember no test is a perfect test
so
It's just it does it's I
The last time I looked at it maybe they changed their prices
It was a couple thousand dollars for the test so if insurance covers it to that's great
But if insurance doesn't cover it then I think it's an expensive test compared to like a tumor marker test
Questions about Rupa labs. We've had this question from a few people about the Rupa labs
One person was disappointed because they ordered
Labs from Rupa labs and then they couldn't get a draw for a
A period of time and then they were told that it could take a couple weeks to get the test back
Now understand any lab is going to tell you it could take a couple weeks to get the test back
If you're getting it depends on what you're getting done if you're getting a direct test
It could take a couple weeks to get a test back. That's a functional medicine test if you're getting a cbc and a
Complete metabolic panel. It usually will come back in a couple days
Rupa is going to always tell you a couple weeks
So you're not disappointed in
And bugging them about whether the test is going to come back
When you order through Rupa labs you'll have the option to order to find a draw site near you
So if you go find a draw site near you could go with your blood drawn right away
You also have the option and this is through most labs if you do any online labs
You'll have the option to get
Flemonymous to come to your house for a price, but usually it's about 80 to 150 dollars to have that done
but then you're
subject to you know compare your schedule with the Flemonymous schedule
It could be a couple weeks before the Flemonymous can schedule to come to your house to do that draw
Don't choose that option if you want to get a blood test done quickly
So if you're looking to get something done quickly, don't choose that option
And please understand we're offering this Rupa lab option to people who can't get their labs done through their local doctor
So this is this is just an add on you know
For people who can't get their labs done, you know some people don't have a local doctor to work with
Well then then this is an option if you have the ability to go through your local doctor
Or through your oncologist to get labs done most time they're going to be covered by insurance too
So it would be best to do it that way
The the Rupa lab option is simply for those people that are like
I don't have a functional doctor anymore. I bird my bridges with my oncologist
He's not going to run anything for me anymore
How do I get labs done? Well, you know, there's positive is the negative Rupa labs understand with the Rupa lab option
We make zero pennies on Rupa lab so it's totally out of our
Hands Rupa makes seven seven percent that's how much they make on the labs
Plus they have to charge $25 per lab
To get a doctor's order so they have a local
position in the state that you're
That you are in that will sign off on the labs
That's that is a huge issue for any practitioner who's doing whose ordering labs for
patients that they may talk to online or that are in a you know, have a practice similar to ours if you live in in in Florida and
I'm ordering a lab for you. That's a real great area of legality
Um, I don't I bet license didn't Florida and you're going to get in a draw in Florida for a lab
You really need a
Florida license doctor to sign off on that lab
That if you want to stay legal we could get in trouble you could get in trouble
So the beauty of Rupa labs is that's how they function they have doctors in every state that our license that can sign off on your lab
Well, there's a fee for that. It's $25 that's added to each of the lab prices
So what I picked the labs to go into our Rupa lab store
I picked the labs that we're going to use most often and they are literally the cost from the lab and then you pay the $25 and then you pay
7% for the Rupa fee for them to send out the kicked and help coordinate you can call them and reschedule and do all that that's what their fee is
We don't make a penny off of it
So I understand if if it ends up becoming
More expensive than if you went to your doctor and you only had to pay a copay well then then to choose that option
It's really for people who don't have that option to choose so um, and then if you have to get something done quickly
It we have one person that they're 200 miles away from any place to get a draw well
Well, then you're kind of stuck you're going to have to drive you know, there's just there's nothing
There's nobody that's going to be able to service
You unless you are able to drive so it's difficult. I understand but we're just trying our best to try to give you a service
That will help people that are in that situation
I have been recommended the blacks have blood cancer since august of 21 erectile cancer. I recently had a cheek swab
Following the surgery indicating that my supplement should remain the same
I'm wondering if that still applies
To my black sat blood root since my larger tested is being temporarily bypassed via the iliostomy
That the blood root may not make it to the larger testin
The answers
Yes, that still applies. So your absorbing we're not
Hilling directly with the black sat capsule your absorbing most of it before it got to that area
It's what's in the black sat blood root capsules
Is blood root which is an herb
raviola
Burdock and shaper elder four different herbs that are really good for cancer not just colon rectal cancer
But really good for different cancers
So yes, you're absorbing that it's going through the bloodstream. It's helping
Our goal is that it helps kill
Cancer cells anywhere it finds them including anesthetic cells
So yes, yes, stay on that for a call
I am taking so far as I'm at four a day astral clear at three a day
and aroma clear
At three a day. I am having hot flashes
Should I take them at a certain time of the day do the hot flashes lead anything bad
No, the hot flashes actually mean that it's working. So you're using so far as I'm which is
Broccoli seed extract product
And astral clear which is
Ligged in to help pull out estrogens and aroma clear which is
I see three and dim and something else to help pull out estrogens
If you effectively pull out estrogens
You will have hot flashes. This is why people on letharzo
Which is a rheumatase inhibitor they'll like it because they're having hot flashes. How can I prevent these hot flashes?
Well the hot flashes are really aside that they're really working
So it's not that you can prevent that really you that's what you're going to get when you
What you do what you're trying to do
A few weeks back I mentioned breaking out in a rash
I've said several places. It's still there around my shoulders lower back
Spine left right thigh and under right knee and sometimes along both calves itchy at different times
Is this a detox reaction or is
Can this be related to liver having too much to filter etc
At what point is it a concern when I first mentioned this I recently changed
Longer detergent as the older was discontinued now. I switched to an organic really rated detergent
So can a person have hives and rash because
They're overwhelmed with their liver and you're trying to detox through the skin. Yes
Another thing that can stimulate hives and rash is a huge emotional change
Stress change stress under your adrenals. I remember when I was in
school
After my finals of my first semester it was so stressful. I literally broke out in a rash all over my body for two weeks
It was the two-week break
From you don't wear because I didn't get any rest for two weeks. I was just under so much stress
That could do it
So can I have a allergy reaction all of a sudden from something that could do it
Um, you know usually if it's from a detergent like I initially said
Um usually that would go away after a period of time. Here's what I would suggest
To try to figure this out
Number one, I would do a cbc
That's a complete blood count which you're really looking for is an increase in eocentophils
Um
To see if if it's an allergic reaction um of something like an allergen to something if there's a spike in eocentophils
Then that's what we really know what's going on. It can be a
um
An allergy to some environmental that's typically what you're going to
Yes, yes, yes in a fill reaction if your cbc is all completely normal. There's nothing abnormal there
Then we just got to keep digging is there a food sensitivity, you know, then then you have to look at that
Uh possibility and you're like well, I've never had food sensitivities before and everybody did anything different in my diet
Well, you can develop antibodies to different foods for a zillion different reason and if if the only way to really know that is
To do a syrex
um array
head and test um to see if something is going on with that
Um the most common foods would be your your your basic most common foods would be gluten dairy
um eggs
uh cord
So you could do a food elimination to see if it's something like that that's going on
If it's like
Well, my liver is overwhelmed you'd have to go well
Again, why would your liver be overwhelmed unless you're
And less you're uh exposed to a whole lot of toxins. I've had people throughout my years. I have a reaction like this because they
Um, they they were farmers and they just tell what um
GMO corn on their field or they just sprayed their field with pesticides and they
weren't very very careful, but they're exposed to a lot of chemicals
Um, and I've had people that were painters and they did a big painting job
Or they did a spray job and they're exposed to a different chemical in a paint like this. I have one person that um
Their child had broken out like this and we couldn't figure out what it was
And actually went over to their house and tested it and in the children's bedroom
They had just moved into a brand new long cabinet. They had painted
With linseed oil on the inside of the cabinet. It's all they stayed it with linseed oil
Well, she said he attested him and he came up our stick toxicity and then the
The mother did some research on linseed oil and found that all linseed oil except if you get a natural organic linseed oil
Which was like four times as expensive
linseed oil needs to be rendered
So it's rendered they add arsenic to the rendering because it speeds up the rendering process
And they can sell it a lot cheaper
So the one bedroom wall where the four kids or the three kids were in bunk beds in that bedroom was still sticky
It just didn't dry correctly and the kids were exposed to the arsenic and the linseed oil
So I would I would kind of search for and maybe you have already done that
I would search for environmental factors that maybe something you're exposed to or
That if you could put your figure on
Just to say oh, it's a detox reaction and then a big fan of you know, just blame me to detox reaction now if let's say
You were eating horribly your whole life and then you just made a major
Change in your diet and you're starting to clean up your diet
You could have a reaction that could last a few days to a week or maybe even two weeks
But this isn't the case with the person who wrote this so I would I think we need to dig a little bit deeper
And see what's going on because I would have thought that this would have cleared up by no so
If you need some help we can chat about that
Some alternative cancer practiceers say that cancer is very smart
And you should alter your approach perhaps changing the way you take care
Do your cynical
I think also to write also changes up application of frequencies for similar reasons thoughts on doing this
Well, certainly if a person's cancer is
Continuing to grow we always want to look at adding different frequencies
The I don't tend to think we need to change the true right frequencies
That often
In our in the case of how I program the rights for people not that I'm special but most people use the her true right
Like an hour a day at maximum. So
We're using it all like long so I put so many different frequencies in your night now. I am not opposed
At all to say hey, I will need to you know totally willing to if you want me to tweak up your programming
I would gladly do that for you
Now I will almost always do that if a person is getting worse or something's metastasized and I tested it comes out that
There will be tweak in their program
So you just you know send it a cheek swab with that request. That's why we put that that's why I put that request on the cheek swab form
You won't be to specifically check for frequency changes
And this is why we've said over and over about the neutrosuiticles to sometimes it can be good to
Do what's uh call
Um, that's not a complete change echo your neutrosuiticles, but but um
Uh
Fall seed your neutrosuiticles. So you might go off for a week
I'm just kind of clean out let your body clean out go off of it for a week
That can be the case with a rash too. You can be developed by sensitivity to actually one of your supplements. That's a possibility
So um
That's think about you know
Paul seeing them instead of pulsing them all off for a week pulse off one at a time for a week see if there's any change in
The rash maybe that's maybe that's possibility. What's going on too
What a caster oil pack help um some inflammation of the lymph node
Any suggestions do dry brushing and some rolling, but some days that area is very sore
You can i mean you can try it. I mean there's there's no like oh
This is what caster else gonna do all the time there's there's you just can't make those blanket statements
Um, we have some people that are doing caster oil packs over there over a breast tumor
We have some people that's tried it and said no it just made it more inflamed it made it worse
Everybody's different so give it a try do it once
I would just do it for start off do it for a short period of time see how it works
And see any changes and don't know any changes and and test it
I have breast cancer our lymphatic massages okay
so
This lymphatic massages. I think are okay if you go to someone who's trained in cancer
massage therapy
Um, I don't think just general lymphatic massages
where they're going really deep um and they could
aggravate a cancer
I don't think that's helpful
um if they're gentle and they're staying away from the sight of the cancer then I think you're fine
But you don't want to physically aggravate a cancer either
So I'd be careful with that
I had a baby in September and was told not to do coffee animals
I am not pregnant now. So how often should I be doing coffee animals
So we have some people that are doing coffee animals daily
We have some people that are really sick that are doing multiple coffee animals a day
We have some people that are doing coffee animals once a week
A couple of times a week is some people that are not doing coffee animals at all
I fit into that category right now. I haven't done a coffee animal for a couple of months now
So um, it really depends on how you're doing if you're doing well and your cancer is
in a relative state of remission do you need to do coffee animals? Well
You've got to go look back at why you would do coffee animals
So number one, the reason why you do coffee animals in my book is to stimulate your parasympathetics
so if you are a fairly
parasympathetic driven person eating it's your really chill pill
You're really calm because your parasympathetics are going to calm your brain. They're going to calm your mind
Let's say if you asked your best friend probably not your husband
But if you asked your best friend do you think I have a lot of anxiety and they were honest to you and said
Yeah, you're kind of a high-strung person you're kind of a lot of anxiety that coffee animals are best for you
If you're like no, you are just so absolute chillier the chillest person I know
Um, if there be it honest then there's maybe a little bit less need for coffee animals
But it's not solely so the parasympathetics do other things so it stimulates your immune system
It stimulates your detoxification pathways
So if you have issues with your detoxification that pathways the coffee animals
will help
Stimulate your detox pathways into your liver
Um, if you're having an increased growth of cancer and you need to hire stimulation of your immune system
coffee animals are the thing to do
Um, so not everybody needs to do coffee animals. Don't
Listen to the stuff out there that if you don't are doing coffee animals
You're not going to get better from your cancer. That's just not true
I have people
Maybe even on this call that have never done a coffee animal in their life and they're
Doing really well with their cancer. So um
It everybody is different last part of this question. I was told to do coffee animals can be dried to the body
Um, I would disagree with that um, so it was suggested to do seaweed animals too thoughts on this
I would disagree with that seaweed animals seaweed is going to be a lot of iodine so
Um, remember what we've talked about with all the latest research on iodine and Hashimoto's so you have any issues with your thyroid and you're taking iodine
Um for any length of time. It's the high possibility that your any hypothyroidism is going to turn in Hashimoto's
Uh, it will stimulate an autoimmune attack on your thyroid. So
Not a big fan of seaweed animals for that reason
I also saw the disturbing articles on Rekola site about the MRDA in our food supply. Is there anything we can do to detox it
So it doesn't accumulate and hurt us as bad
Well, there's no perfect way to detox the MRDA because there's just not enough note about it
Now, I've always said that the lumbarol
kites
And natto kites
um
Is
Oh, why did I change that um
Uh, is uh
Is some of the best things to help detox the MRDA plus your binders
So natto kites and lumbarol kites are enzymes
Um, we actually have a brand new product that we actually have two brand new
uh, private label products. What is called
circulation um
Clear clear circulation um
And the other one is uh
clear talks
So clear talks was actually created specifically
To detox
The MRDA vaccine. It has lumbarol kites and it has natto kites. So does the circulation clear has lent lumbarol kites and certain and natto kites
But if you have um, you know issues from the vaccine or from being exposed to people with the vaccine and having heart issues
I would take the circulation clear
If you're like no, I don't have any of those issues. I just don't want to have issues
I'm trying to detox this MRDA vaccine then take the clear talks
Uh, clear talks just has some other binders and things in it that circulation that clear has the more things that it supports your heart
Um, the clear talks has more things in it has both the lumbarol kites and natto kites both of them do
But it also has stuff in there to help detox the toxin. So
Uh, after taking a 14-day prednisone treatment and finished and then waiting three weeks after can a can the prednisone affect the results of a PET scan
Huh, I don't know. You'll have to ask the radiologist that
I don't know. I don't think so
And I don't know the answer to that
For sure
What is the Rupa lab test that we've been talking about the Rupa lab test is the is not a lab test. It's a it's a Rupa
Is a company that we partnered with in order to be able to support to give
uh
To offer labs to you and our members
So it's all over our member site that we could now order labs. It's through our partner Rupa labs
I
have experienced pain in my spine at the location where I had surgery. Could this be part of the healing process or a side of the disease
The answer is yes, could be either
um
And the only
way to
orderly know if it's the task size to that area is a PET scan or a CT scan would see some see that too
um
It's uh
But you it can be healing too. So you know as as you're healing from an injury you're going to have pain
So I know you know we said this before whatever we have cancer and you know any pain or any symptom we go
Oh, it's getting worse, but you know and that may be true, but it's not always true
So we just got to be careful not to go there mentally
um
The only way to know for sure is to do a scan to see what's going on
So if the pain is
excruciating and it's you know
That's what another way to know if that
If if the pain is unbearable, it's very high on a scale or one to 10 that's not normal
It's that normal healing pain that I would definitely talk to the doctor about that
I read it a book called the metabolic approach to cancer
By Dr. Dasha winter sun page 125 it talks about
human breast milk and calls it the most incredible superfood on the planet
And says some adults are using it to fight against their cancer
Apparently researchers in Sweden discovered that a substance found in the human breast milk
selective ability to kill cancer cells
I have a knee who pumps breast milk and is willing to supply me with rows and best breast milk
You think it'd be a good idea for me to drink this. I would my late 50s
And was not breastfed as a baby
Well, I do you know think that human breast milk is amazing and all my children were breastfed
You know until they
Well, we are worried where we need a lot later than most people are we need these days
all my
grandchildren were breastfed
And are still breastfed some of them
And so it is amazing it has different antibodies to fight different diseases and all sorts of different things
Do I think there's a down side?
No, not really. I don't think so
My that's rather doctor says ultrasound is radiation
Just non ionizing
well
From a basic standpoint everything is radiation the sunshine is radiation
um
So yeah, technically the answer is correct, but when we're talking about
radiation that is dangerous to your body
Then yeah, I guess I guess your and D is correct. It is radiation. It's not ionizing radiation. It's not going to damage cells
Problem is studies show ionizing radiation is not as safe as we were once told
The dark side of creating a lot of ultrasounds blah blah blah. Yeah
Yeah, I would agree there can be you know
A downside to doing to any prenatal ultrasounds or
But again, it's a much less invasive way to look at um and to measure something. So
We use ultrasound as a therapy tool. So
ultrasound can be therapeutic as you as those ultrasonic waves go through there to help clean
out the tissue and help to detox tissue as well and a healing mode
Um, can there be downsides to anything there can be
Again, you know, you do any task because you're you're looking for data because it may change the way you treat
um, so
And that's how you measure that there can be downsides to too much ultrasound
I in a in a pure world. Yes, but there can be upsides because it can really help
Determine how you're moving forward and what you need to do
I did two baking soda wraps that I watched on Barbara O'Neil's YouTube and now I am feeling depleted
I don't feel good now is this normal? Oh, I don't know um, I have not ever done a baking soda wrap
And I'm really not even familiar with a baking soda wrap that this person
Advocates um
So baking soda is sodium bicarbonate
And it's a strong base now the whole idea of acid base balance
um
And you know if any of you have been with me long enough have heard my take on that
And that oh cancer can grow in an
Alcholid environment as you need to alkalize your body and cancer is only grows in an acidic environment
To me that is just a bunch of hui
So I think any highly metabolic
Cell is going to produce a lot of waste and that waste is going to be acidic
Um, it's not because it's not growing because it's an acidic environment. It's creating the acidic environment
Now, I know doctor Steven Gini
eject baking soda
At the site of the cancer had some success
How much success he had we don't know he ended up getting thrown in jail in Italy for what he did
We have no idea maybe he got thrown in jail because he was helping people
Maybe it's throwing jail because he hurt people
We just don't know I do think that if you injected baking soda
At the site of a cancer
To be it makes sense that it would actually help from a physiological standpoint because they at the site of the cancer is very acidic
However to get making soda or to get an alkaline solution at the site of a cancer you'd have to inject it
If you're going to ingest it
taking it orally and you don't have cancer in the stomach or the first part of the small intestine
It's just going to break down and you're not you're just making your stomach alkaline
That's like taking alkaline water to me it makes no physiological sense whatsoever because you're just
alkalizing your stomach acid which you're
Just completely counterintuitive to to your how your body has to use hydrochloric acid to digest
Plus you have what's called a buffer in system in your body that will buffer
Anything
But if you expose yourself to too much acid you can make yourself ill for a period of time
You expose yourself to too much
base or alkaline
Product you can make yourself ill so don't just think because it's alkaline. It's good. You know a high degree of alkalinity
It's just as caustic as a high is a
low pH of a low acidic solution is caustic you want to burn somebody you know you spill some
sulfuric acid on them you want to burn somebody with some high
You know a concentration of a high pH product that you can still burn somebody
It's just as caustic and this is dangerous. So the idea you're going to measure pH on a person is
Is really ridiculous. You can't measure
urinary or salivary pH and say this person is
alkaline or
Acidic it all it says is there a urine is alkaline acidic and if you give a person some minerals
They'll probably alkalize their urine because they'll spill extra minerals in their urine which is
Which is how your body
buffers the acid-based system
So um, I don't know. I just drink a lot of water
personally
Try to flush anything out of your body
And just get your body back and balance that way. That's what I would do with anything
Remember this that's one of the best ways to help your body in any
hyper exposure of anything whether it's a hyper exposure of
Polytor hyper exposure of you know
bad food, you know drink a lot of water the the old saying that
dilution is the solution to pollution is just is a cute little saying that it's so true
Your body if you dilute it you're going to help
Decrease the pollution and help flush out
That thing of your body whatever that is
If my AFP is still elevated. This is a tube marker
After we remove the tumors what is elevated it?
So um
Your tumor markers that remember so first of all all the tumor marker tests all the tumor marker tests are just physiological tests
They're not only produced by tumors
Otherwise, if you don't have any cancer, they'd all be zero
They're never zero. There's a normal range
So um
There it's never gonna go down to zero um and
You don't want it to other things that your body make that chemical
It's just found that growing tumors
tend to make that specific chemical in greater concentration
Therefore you could use it as a marker of cancerous growth
If you have solely a breast tumor, let's say and you remove your breast
And there is no metastasis anywhere else by any visual means that we can tell them with a pet scan
And you still show elevated tumor markers after you have the breast treatment. Why
Are you still showing elevated tumor markers? Well
The answer is I don't know for sure
Um, could it be that you have hidden metastasis? That is a possibility
Um, remember even on a pet scan wherever we said any no test is perfect and even with a pet scan you have to have
Uh cancerous mass of over three million cells large to even show up positive on a pet scan
So there is a possibility that there is still some metastasis in the body
Um, there's a possibility that
Maybe other cells are producing that tumor marker
Um, and a greater concentration than our cancerous so we just don't know
Maybe it's gonna take some time for that to go down. Somebody asked me a question similar to this
A while back um several months ago that they're because their tumor marker how long does it take for two markers to go down
And I said well, I have just seen in practice that sometimes it takes a while even after
You're out of chemo or after you're doing the right thing the tumor marker still stays elevated and the question was the thing the following week
Well, why would that be and this is very confusing
Well, it is very confusing. This is why none of these tests are perfect. So
Um, but this is why this is honestly this is why a lot of oncologists have stopped using tumor markers because if you're going to do what they tell you to do
Which is do the chemo therapy lots of times that makes two marker go on
So if you kill the tumors effectively with what's called
Uh something that will cause cell lysis
That it can actually spill more of the tumor marker out and you could elevate it and then patient goes
Because oh it because they they they hey I agreed to do this chemo and I'm getting worse according to the tumor marker test so
It's kind of a lot of oncologists just don't do those. That's why I have to ask for them. So there isn't the perfect science to any of this um
As we get frustrated with science, but the truth is it's nothing is perfect and we don't have a perfect way to see inside your body
Know exactly what's going on
So
Hopefully it's going to go down. That's what we wanted to go down. We want to
Again, this is why we don't ever just look at one test
So you want to look at other things and compare us and see
What else is going on if you know that we can look at any other objective things and subjective things
Instead of wrapping in wet towels and blankets, I dipped my clothes and laid them
laid in my infrared sauna
So you're talking about the baking soda wrap. So instead of wrapping in wet towels and blankets
I dipped my clothes and laid in my infrared sauna. Okay, so
Um, all right, so I've never wrapped in wet towels and blankets in my infrared sauna
Still not fully understated with it as I guess I'll have to watch that video
um
I am putting in castor oil in my breast to where it has been the only thing that has stopped the bleeding
So this goes back to that other question about castor oil on their um
tumor
But now there's a lot of white blotches and lines that look like fungus
What do you suggest that I do to deal with the white
fungus coming out of the tumor if anything so
If there's stuff coming out of the tumor
To be that's almost always a good thing
Um
If it's a fungus, you can certainly put some hydrogen peroxide in a bottle and
And squirt a little bit of that
The on the open wound you can use some colloidal silver
In a bottle and squirt a little bit that you know treat that a couple times a day
In an alternate maybe those two I would do those two things
Um
I don't think the castor oil is either fungus
Um, but it may be dried it out
so um
Those two suggestions might help kill it if it is
Does Rupa replace the exebia or the well-of-a test? Yes, it does
And the reason it does is for what I said, you know, when we were doing the well-of-a test
That was getting us in potential hot water because
um
You really need a licensed doctor in your state legally to okay and approve
and quote unquote order a test for you
so
We were in really great area there in the issues
At that um any board could come after us and say that we're practicing medicine in your state by ordering a test for
somebody in ill and oh, I
They'd have a case against us. So using Rupa
We're not ordering the test. They're getting an ill and oh, I licensed doctor
That's basically siding off on the order
They're first keeping it completely legal for everybody
In surgery, they uh
They said they got all the cancer fantastic
Um my pet scan the week before surgery showed cancer nowhere else in my body
Would the hospital consider me in remission um
I would say yeah, they probably would every every clinic group may have a different
definition of
remission typically it's
uh
What's called any d-go evidence of disease
Really that in all their testing, they can't see anything find any disease, you know
Show anything positive on a pet scan and there's I mean that would be a no evidence of disease
My Ft is elevated. I'm doing your supplements throughout loss has been five deductions for the stem cells
Don't chemo no radiation no toxin
Any approvals or rewards regarding this
Also you think it's worth taking the hoxy tonic is that worth it
Um, I know you you're probably taking you're taking a lot of stuff already. I don't know if I would add anything
So
Remember too much of the thing can be bad thing we talk about taking too many supplements can
affect your liver and can put stress on your liver because your liver has to detox by those two so be careful of that
What are your thoughts about taking
Uh Celtics salt
Um
You've got to be careful with any salt
So remember just because you have cancer does it mean you don't have
other
Issues like autoimmune issues so in my book I write I think
That a lot of people with cancer. There's an autoimmune component to it
Um, and if you go through the the chronic disease in autoimmune
um
Course
You'll learn that one of the things that can cause a flare of autoimmune diseases too much salt
Any salt pink salt Celtic salt any any salt whatsoever
Can cause a flare of autoimmune disease
In a certain group of people it also caused high blood pressure in a certain group of people issues too
And those are really real. I don't care. You know what video you
Show me or watch that says that this certain pink salt or this Emily and soldier this salt is so good for you because it's kind of minerals in it and everything
Well, the truth is it's still a salt and the minerals in there are really stone minerals or earth minerals
Which are not with a kind of minerals you're supposed to be eating anyhow you're supposed to be eating vegetables that take earth minerals
Uh, which are
Uh, inorganic hard solids and salts and turns it into a mineral that's double bonded
to an amino acid and then we consume that
That um that product which is a vegetable that's why the only minerals that we sell
That we private label in our store our minerals that are double bonded
Um to an amino acid the same way that you would get them in
eat by eating vegetables so
I would say I pass on that as iodine is iodine as in supplement not a good idea to take
Well iodine can be helpful for people with breast cancer, but I still say only in a very shorter basis
In general, so if a person is taking iodine
Especially as a female
You have an increased risk of
I've created a Hashimoto's disorder. So
iodide is necessary for my my thyroid to produce T3 you say well, that's very true, but it's very very small about an iodine if you take
any iodide in a mineral supplement or iodide straight um of any um
um
Solution you risk increasing a
Stimulation on your thyroid planet increasing a stimulation of your immune system and creating a Hashimoto's and then that puts
A TPO antibody production at a thyroid lab in an antibody production. So
long term, yes, I'd say
You should hold off on that
Just did my mouth cheek swab with you and you stated to back off
To only one burger clear. What is the reason for that?
It's just because that's what tested so when I test things I test for a dosage. So that's that's just what tested
So
Have you seen the rife keel cancer? Have you seen rife keel cancer in the bone?
Yes, for sure. Yes
So remember that's the beauty of the rife. I mean, so let me step back
It's if you were doing chemotherapy. Let's say a person has cancer this metastasized to their bone
um statistically chemotherapy is not
It'll work that well because you you do have blood supply to the bone
But it's limited you know, it's it's it's um it's hard to get
um
Healy nutrients to the bone just like it's hard to get healy nutrients to the brain
Because you have blood brain barrier
Well, you do have a blood supply to the bone, but it is limited and it's it's it's difficult to get that there
So even chemotherapy to the bone it's going to be difficult. That's why they would typically suggest radiation
To the bone to kill the cancer which I think can be a really good idea
I've seen it over and over again you see radiation
To the cancer can be amazing
Because you can do just a few sessions and it can kill all the cancer in that bone
So on if if a person has metastasis to the bone and it's causing issues
should
We just for everybody, but you could knock it down just
Very quick with radiation. So don't be dogmatic in a position against radiation
However, it's hard to get nutrients in your immune system and t cells to go and kill something in the bone
Um
That's where the rife is so beautiful because the frequencies are going right through you so
The rife is going to go right into your brain the rife is going to go right into your bone
Um, so that's a huge huge benefit
Uh, I bought the whole
Zolia series and watched your video episode eight last night very good
Okay, so that must have been something I was interviewed in
Okay, well, that's great fantastic
I don't remember what that is though and I've never listened to one of my videos
For interviews in my entire life
Sorry, but I can't stay listening myself
The husband feels that the rife is causing his ears to ring does this make sense to you
well
It's possible. I mean just the
The toe the the noise of the rife could irritate
A tenitis so that is possible for sure
Um, I'd try to muffle it maybe put a pillow over the machine so you muffle the noise a little bit
Um, possibly have him wear earplugs to men see if that makes a difference
Um to see if it is the noise of the rife that's doing that
You can't so when a person has tonight is any any any audible frequency can be a stimulant that
That um, it'll be irritated so that is possible
There was a margin of less than one millimeter of when the surgeon removed my tuber from the
actor Alice muscle
Why do you think she didn't take a deeper margin?
She passed away a month after my surgery suddenly unexpectedly
Oh, so I can't ask her is that a thin margin that's dangerous
Well understand she may have thought she took a much bigger margin
But then when that sample is sent to the lab
They measure that margin and that was measured at one millimeter
There's no way she can see the male the margin to be one millimeter. She'd have to
You know, this is not physically able to see that also she might have not wanted to damage your pectoralis muscle muscle anymore
Is you cut the fibers of the muscle?
I mean you cut the fibers so
um
You'd have to you can't stitch up the individual fiber. You're going to damage the muscle. So maybe that's it
Speaking to her passing away suddenly, that's very sad
Oh, I just talked to a doctor friend of mine who just got a job at Mayo in December
Um, that he had to he was forced to get the vaccine in December he was at another hospital
And they allowed him they accepted his religious exemption to not get the vaccine, but that hospital system was bought out and
He was going to lose his job like a whole bunch of other people and he was off from job at Mayo
But they made him get the vaccine. He told me yesterday he was I have I'm not been the same
I just but it's just changed my life 100% 100% that's what he said
um, so
um
Right to help him
So I would say that it was that was the margin of
Less than a millimeter was found on the pathology sample
But to be honest, it's found on the pathology sample and it's a margin of one millimeter
It's a margin. That's all you need is a margin. So um, you know, you don't need a you know, I think a margin of one millimeter
Which should we take it a margin of a centimeter? That would have been better. Really? I don't know. I don't think so. I mean
Just take your whole pack muscle and you're not going to get any cancer there. It's that's not in the case
It's your you are your goal right now is to like keep all your circulated to ourselves at bay
You're everything you do with a knife on a daily basis
Um, and everything you're doing with it everything else on a daily basis. Your nutrition is to help kill circulated to ourselves
I'll tell you. I'll put it out there right now
I can't tell you how many people that we find out that they you know have passed away this is doing this for 25 years now
And we get their right back and they stop using their right seven months ago or a year ago because they thought they were cured
And um and their cancer quote-a-quote came back with the vengeance
And then they were so sick they didn't even start using it again and they passed away
Well
Remember circulate to ourselves will not show up on a PET scan
You everybody's got them everybody's got cancer cells even if you've never been diagnosed with cancer keep using your right don't stop
don't get lazy
Um don't think you don't use it anymore continue to use it on a daily basis
All right with that will say goodbye and
um
Know that I'm praying for you guys all and foot baths too um not necessarily
But continue to use your life
And um
Tell next week if you need personal attention make sure you call it scheduled time with me too. All right. Love you all. Bye-bye
you